this mobile phone video surfaced last
month on social media
there's not a dog here the man says
their bodies are now speed bumps for the
road the video was believed to be shot
in Janina the capital of Sudan's West
Darfur state where Violence by militias
has killed thousands of people mainly
from the masalit tribe now a U.N human
rights report says some bodies have been
buried in a mass grave just outside
jinena the agency says at least 37
bodies were buried on 20th June in the
approximately one meter deep Mass grave
another 50 bodies were buried at the
same site on 21st June the bodies of
seven women and seven children were
among those buried
the UN panel says it has credible
information those buried were killed by
the paramilitary rapid support forces
and their Allied militia
the violence in West Darfur a state
already marred by two decades of war was
the result of a power vacuum a Sudan's
Army and the paramilitary rapid support
forces battled for power in the capital
hartum and other states
hundreds of thousands have fled from
Janina to neighboring Chad since April
many recounted the horrors they've
witnessed
[Music]
I left my family behind including my
wife and children I left them in the
fighting there was no Force to protect
civilians the rapid support forces
attacked us from every side even in
streets when we tried to flee
they didn't leave people alive they
attacked people and the dead were left
on the streets
[Music]
many refugees say they had to leave sick
and injured family members behind the
U.N report says some of those buried in
the grave include those who died from
untreated injuries Health Facilities
have been destroyed in the violence and
Telecommunications were cut off as
thousands crossed the border every day
seeking safety Sudan's Army says the U.N
report provides a glimpse of the crimes
committed by the paramilitary group its
fighting and accused the rsf of war
crimes and crimes against humanity the
paramilitary has previously blamed what
it calls Outlaws for the violence in
Darfur
the human rights commissioner has urged
the rsf to stop the violence but with
most of those who were targeted already
dead or across the border and after more
than two months of fighting many see the
call as coming too late Heber Morgan Al
Jazeera